MORE ON TOP STORY LEFT WING
MEDIA CANNOT BELIEVE TRUMPMEDIAP
RECEIVED A CLEAN BILL OF
HEALTH.
THEY’RE LOOKING FOR ANY EXCUSE
TO DISCREDIT RESULTS BEYOND
PATHETIC.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN HE SAID 239 POUNDS.
>> WHATEVER.
>> I KNOW I’M BEING GIRTHER.
>> IF THAT’S WHAT 6’ 3, 239
POUNDS LOOKS LIKE IT’S A SHOCK
TO MY HE.
>> NOT SURE IF IT MAKES ME
FEEL BETTER THAT THE DOCTOR
SAYS HE HAS NO COGNITIVE
ISSUES.
IT MAKES ME FEEL WORSE GOOD
YOU COVERED THE MAN FOR
DECADES.
>> YES.
>> YOU FEEL LIKE YOU’VE SEEN
CHANGES.
I’M NOT A DOCTOR BUT I CAN SEE
HE IS NOT THE SHARP MIND THAT
HE WAS WHEN I FIRST MET HIM.
>> JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
REACTION IS AUTHOR OF BEST
SELLING BOOK "VENGEANCE" NEWT
GINGRICH AND YOU SAW THEGINGRICE
PRESSER YESTERDAY, I STILL
CANNOT BELIEVE WHAT I SAW.
BONE SPURS?
TOO MUCH TWEETING?
TV?
AND ONE SCOOP OR TWO?
IS HE DRUG ADDICT?
DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE DEN
TURZ?
AND DOES THE PRESIDENT NEED
SEDATION?
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER HAD TO
UNDERGO THIS GARBAGE.
IT’S FUNNY BUT IT’S REALLY A
SICK SIDE TO THIS.
>> WELL LET ME SAY FIRST OF
ALL AS A HISTORIAN WHILE HE
DON’T IT IN THE PRESS ROOM
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WAS ATTACKED
WITH THE SAME SAVAGERY AND
SAME VICIOUSNESS AS TRUMP AND
I THINK LOOK I’M A HAWK ON
THIS ALL RIGHT?
AND I THINK SHE THEY SHOULD
LINE UP EVERY ONE OF THE MOST
ID OTIC COMMENTS AND PUT THEM
OWN YouTUBE AND HAVE THUMBS
UNAND THUMBS DOWN.
THUMBS UP MEANS THEY GET TO
STAY.
AND THUMBS DOWN, KICK HIM OUT
EVER THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE NO OBLIGATION AS
PRESIDENT TO HAVE IDIOT --
>> ROLE WOULD BE EMPTY.
>> AND -- BE.
>> THE ROLE WILL BE EMPTY.
MAYBE YOU KEEP LIBERAL JOEMAYBED
DR. MIKA.
>> IT WOULD NOT BE EMPTY.
>> PRETTY CLOSE.
>> IT WOULD NOT BE EMPTY YOU
GO TO LOCAL TV STATIONS AND
SAY DO YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TRY OUT BEING
WHITE HOUSE SUPPORTER.
AND YOU GET A WHOLE NEW
GENERATION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT JADED AND PART OF
WASHINGTON GANG.
THEY DON’T SIT AROUND EVERY
AFTERNOON EVERY COCKTAIL
TALKING ABOUT HOW UTTERLY
STUPID TRUMP IS AND CREATE A
WHOLE GENERATION OF REPORTERS.
HE HAD HE COUNT INDICTMENT END
OF NEXT WEEK.
THE FIX WAS IN WITH COMEY AND
IS THAT THE BACK BEFORE
CONGRESS AND DOSSIER ISCONGRESSS
BLOWING UP AND I’M TOLD WE
WILL HAVE NEWS TO SHOCK THE
CONSCIOUS.
HERE’S MY QUESTION.
YOU HAVE HILLARY AND WE NOW
KNOW RIGGED PRIMARY AGAINST
BERNIE WE HAVE NO SHOT AND
DONNY BRAZIL CONFIRMS IT AND
PAYING FOR RUSSIAN LIES AND
PROPAGANDA TO INFLUENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND RIG THAT
ELECTION AND THEN HAD COMEY
INSTRUCT BECAUSE THEY SO
WANTED HER THEY RIGGED
INVESTIGATION EXXON RATION
BEFORE INVESTIGATION AND WITH
ALL WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
MEDIA, THERE’S VERY FEW OF US
DISCUSSING THIS.
AND I DON’T MIND BEING OUT ON
A LIMB.
I HAVE DONE IT MY WHOLEI HAVE DE
CAREER.
BUT NOW IT MATTERS BECAUSE THE
CONSTITUTION IS ENDPLAY.
YOUR REACTION.
>> I AGREE.
IT’S VERY PAR TLOL WHAT THEY
DID YESTERDAY ABOUT THE HEALTH
QUESTION.
HOW CONTACT "WASHINGTON POST",
OR "NEW YORK TIMES", GETS UP
IN THE MORNING AND LOOK AT
THEMSELVES AND NOT COVER THIS?
I MEAN, THERE IS SOMETHING
REALLY THAT’S ALMOST
PATHOLOGICAL, BECAUSE AS
YOU’RE POINTING OUT, WEEK
AFTER WEEK, MORE AND MORE
THINGS ARE COMING OUT AND IT’S
NOT JUST HEARSAY OR
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING, AS
YOU POINT OUT, AN 11 COUNT
INDICTMENT AND FRANKLY BECAUSE
I HAD TALKED TO YOU EARLIER
TODAY I TALKED TO BUSINESS
PEOPLE A WHILE AGO THAT SAID
TO ME OH, WELL, HOW DO YOU
THINK ALL THIS WILL PLAY OUT
AND THEY CLEARLY WERE THINKING
ONLY OF TRUMP.
I THINK 11 COUNT INDICTMENT ON
URANIUM ONE DOESN’T BODE WELL
FOR MILLIFOR FORRY.
THEY KNOW NOTHING ABOUT TAKEN
SHOCK OCCURRED.
AND I THINK YOU BEGIN TO SEAT
THE PIECES COME TOGETHER IN
WHAT I THINK WILL ONLY BE
UNBELIEVABLY BIG SCANDAL AND
MAKES ME FEEL THAT DEFEAT OF
HILLARY EVEN MORE IMPORTANT
THAN ELECTING TRUTHP,
DEFEATING HILLARY SO THE THE
CORRUPTION COULD NOT GO ON AND
NOT BE NOTICED.
BECAUSE.
>> IT’S A CARTEL.
>> AN I AGREE WITH YOU
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND I BELIEVE
SHE IS IN DEEP TROUBLE.
>> CLEARLY SHE’S IN TROUBLE.
THE FOUNDATION IS IN TROUBLE.
AND I THINK FRANKLY COMEY IS
IN TROUBLE AND I THINK YOU
KNOW, 98% OF FBI ARE
HONORABLE, HARDWORKING SERIOUS
PEOPLE.
>> AGREED.
>> BUT AT THE TOP THEY HAD A
LAYER REALLY HAD BEEN
CORRUPTED AND DEPOSIT EVEN